this episode is made possible by
Skillshare home to over 17,000 classes
that could help you learn a new life
skill get your first 3 months for just
99 cents when you sign up for skill
share using the link below America land
of the free and home of the brave one of
the wealthiest most powerful nations on
earth and just a little obsessed with
being number one and we're being number
one is concerned the US has quite a list
of little victories besides spending
more on national defense than China
Saudi Arabia Russia the United Kingdom
India France and Japan combined the u.s.
also has the most Super Bowl wins at an
astounding 50 vs. 0 for the rest of the
world the most cheese produced by any
country if you count American cheese and
the largest population of bald eagles in
the world but it's not always a good
thing to be number one in a recent study
commissioned by the United Nations the
US was determined to be well on its way
to becoming the world champion in
extreme economic and social inequality
the complete list of problems outlined
in the report is pretty eye-opening
especially when the US is compared with
other developed nations in this video
we'll take a brief look at some of the
issues facing America going into 2018
first despite spending far more per
capita on health care than any other
developed nation Americans can expect to
live shorter and sicker lives compared
to people living in any other rich
democracy and this health gap between
the US and its peer countries continues
to grow we also have the highest rate of
obesity in the developed world as well
as alarming rates of malnutrition the
Organisation for Economic Cooperation
and Development or OECD tracks national
policies for countries around the world
and helps determine new policies
designed to improve people's lives
according to the report America has the
highest incarceration rate of any nation
on earth ahead of turkmenistan El
Salvador Cuba Thailand and the Russian
Federation at nearly five times the OECD
average this problem is compounded by
the existence of private for-profit
prisons and the underreporting of
incarceration rates in some states in
terms of childhood health and economic
status America performs very poorly
compared to its developed peers as of
2013 the US infant mortality rate was
the highest in the developed world for
the children that survived the outlook
is still pretty bleak the youth poverty
rate in the United States is the high
across the OECD with fully one-quarter
of youth living in poverty the Stanford
center on poverty and inequality says
the u.s. is a clear and consistent
outlier in the child poverty league as
US child poverty rates are continually
the highest among the six richest
countries the Stanford center also ranks
the most well-off countries in terms of
labor markets poverty safety net wealth
inequality and economic mobility the US
comes in dead last of the top ten most
well-off countries and 18th among the
top 21 the report makes it clear that
the u.s. holds some pretty undesirable
titles but why is that how can such a
wealthy powerful and technologically
advanced nation have such extreme
economic disparity part of the problem
stems from America's stance on economic
and social rights successive
administrations have repeatedly rejected
the idea that these economic and social
rights are full-fledged human rights
despite their clear recognition in
treaties the US has ratified
international human rights law
recognizes the right to education a
right to health care a right to social
protection for those in need and a right
to an adequate standard of living the
report states that in practice the
United States is alone among developed
countries in insisting that while human
rights are of fundamental importance
they do not include rights that guard
against dying of hunger dying from a
lack of access to affordable health care
or growing up in a context of total
deprivation if the US doesn't
acknowledge these needs as basic human
rights then it's no surprise there are
so many people living in extreme poverty
the nation's wealth is funneled into
things deemed more critical most notably
the bloated national defense budget so
if the people running the country don't
want to fix these problems what can we
do that's where the second part of the
problem comes in the United States is
supposed to be a nation by the people
and for the people but for some reason
or several reasons the people aren't
speaking up only about 55 and a half
percent of the u.s. voting age
population cast ballots in the 2016
presidential election in the OECD the
u.s. came 28th and voter turnout
compared with an average of 75 percent
registered voters also represent a much
smaller share of potential voters in the
u.s. than just about any other OECD
country only about 64% of the u.s.
voting age population was registered in
2016 compared with 91% in Canada and the
UK 96% in Sweden and near
9% in Japan these two issues form a
vicious cycle the administration doesn't
acknowledge the growing problem with
extreme wealth inequality in the country
the people don't vote in leaders who do
want to fix the problem and it happens
all over again disturbingly it's not
just the fault of unmotivated voters in
just this past election we've seen
dramatic gerrymandering of electoral
districts to privilege particular groups
of voters the imposition of artificial
and unnecessary voter ID requirements
the blatant manipulation of polling
station locations and the relocating of
DMVs to make it more difficult for
certain groups to obtain IDs this has
resulted in people living in poverty
minorities and other disfavored groups
being systematically deprived of their
voting rights and so the cycle continues
the poor stay poor because they're not
represented and often can't even vote to
elect someone who might make a
difference as more and more children are
born into poverty and the economic
divide grows we'll begin to see a very
paradoxical crisis in which one of the
wealthiest nations on earth hosts the
largest population of homeless starving
uneducated and deeply impoverished ok so
the US has some problems but what can we
do about it
what can the average citizen do to
change a political and societal
atmosphere that completely ostracizes
such a large portion of the population
that's the million-dollar question or
rather several billion dollar question
as large scale changes to social
policies will likely incur a huge cost
but at the end of the day most people
would hopefully say it's worth it as
more and more people realize their
government might not have their best
interest at heart it wouldn't be such a
surprise to see the next few generations
of voters speaking up and demanding real
changes to the way the country is run is
comparing very different nations the
best way to measure success or failure
maybe maybe not but highlighting ways in
which any country has room to improve
should be met with gratitude since
improving our lives and those of our
neighbors is all that really matters in
the end what do you think is the United
States on the right track or has it gone
off the rails in recent years what
changes would you like to see to
economic or social policy let us know
your thoughts in the comments below here
on second thought I'd like to start the
new year with a new resolution this year
my resolution is to learn more advanced
animation techniques from my videos to
do that I'm using classes from
Skillshare Skillshare is an online
learning community
for creators featuring over 17,000
classes in graphic design animation
photography and more that could help you
learn a new skill a premium membership
from Skillshare is more affordable than
most other online learning platforms and
gives you unlimited access to amazing
classes from experts working in their
fields so you can improve your skills
unlock opportunities and do the work you
love as a special offer for second
thought fans you can get your first 3
months with Skillshare for just 99 cents
when you sign up using the link below
that offer is only valid through January
so make sure to visit Skillshare and get
started learning your new skill today if
you enjoyed this video consider
subscribing to support the channel and
click the little bell to join the
notification squad you can watch my
previous video by clicking here
or if you've got a bit more time to kill
you can binge watch all my content by
clicking here thanks for watching and
I'll see you next week
you